hello
i'm alexander rose the executive
director here at long now
i'm joining you tonight from the
interval and julia watson will be
joining from brooklyn
where she's going to watch the edited
version of this talk with all of us as
well as
answer your questions online julia is
from australia where a few years ago the
mega fires
were devastating portions of the country
and she started asking what are the
indigenous technology solutions to these
large environmental problems
and then she started researching them in
countries around the world
she's now put this together into a book
that tashan published that is really one
of the most beautifully illustrated
and photographed books i've seen in a
long time
julia has put together a few of these
stories for us tonight and she's going
to share them with us
welcome julie watson thank you for that
introduction xander
i have admired the work of the long now
foundation for a really long time
since it was introduced to me by one of
my colleagues
and also a long now alum dr steven
lansing and i'm extraordinarily honored
to be able to speak with you
today about my work so i'd like to begin
by acknowledging that i'm speaking to
you today
from the traditional land of the first
people of brooklyn
new york the lenape people past and
present and i want to honor
with gratitude their land and also
the traditional lenape tribe
one of the most vivid memories of my
childhood was
sitting down transfixed and watching
the exxon valdez oil spill and i'm sure
some of you
out there can recall this terrible
disaster at four minutes to midnight
on march 24th in 1989
as a tanker was sailing across the
prince william sound
it struck reef called bly that was a
well-known navigational hazard
the impact of that collision tore open
the entire
hull of the ship and 11 million gallons
of crude oil then began to leak into the
ocean
and initial attempts to contain this oil
field failed and it eventually ended up
spreading about 1 300 miles
up the coast and this was the worst oil
spill that the u.s had ever seen right
up until 2010
when we saw deepwater horizon
so before this disaster prince william
sound had been this
incredible haven for wildlife and
biodiversity but
this disaster took incredible toll on
the wildlife
it killed an estimated 250 000
seabirds 3 000 otters 300 seals and 250
bald eagles
as well as 22 killer whales and it also
played
a major role in the collapse of the
herring
and the salmon fisheries later on in the
sound
after days of sitting there transfixed
and just
watching people washing birds with
household detergent i walked into our
family kitchen
and i announced to my parents that i was
going to
become a marine biologist when i grew up
and then for months after watching this
catastrophe i'd sit there and i would be
wondering
you know what are we here for and who is
actually out there
protecting the environment and who's
protecting
all these animals that i'd seen on the
television so while i didn't
actually follow through on my 11 year
old
promise to my family to become a marine
biologist i did follow through
in my dedication and my interest to
conserving the environment and instead
of marine biology
i ended up studying architecture and in
my second year
i took a course that was called
aboriginal
environments i suddenly realized that i
really didn't have
much of an idea about the spaces that i
was designing
and then after architecture school i
went on to study landscape architectures
so i could explore this idea
of different ways that different
communities
live with nature and design their spaces
and since then i've traveled the world
trying to prove
this idea and the suspicion that i had
about
communities and cultures that live
really closely with nature that
they had already developed some of the
most sustainable innovations
and those innovations were actually
rooted in indigenous
cultures and their knowledge and they'd
figured out these innovations
a really long time ago and so in the
past 30 years while
my focus hasn't really changed that much
i have actually found
some answers to those questions that 11
year old me
was asking myself and today i'm a
landscape architect i teach
at harvard and columbia university and
last year i wrote a book titled low tech
designed by radical indigenism
so the title of the book is a bespoke
word that i completely made up
it's a combination of two concepts or
two words
low tech low tech was a word that's
pretty common to most of us and tek
but what it is it's actually a bit of a
provocation to
us and to really think about what are
our inherited views and our inherited
biases that we have towards local
cultures
and their technologies and mistakenly
these
low-tech technologies of indigenous
cultures they're often referred to as
low-tech low and primitive
rather than what they are which is
sophisticated embodying
all the same types of conditions of
sustainability that we reference today
which is
low embodied energy low cost
efficiency closed-loop systems so moving
on to tek
now this means traditional ecological
knowledge and it's the foundational
knowledge
that the book actually talks about and
it's cumulative
body of multi-generational knowledge
practices
and beliefs and tk is a system
of nested concepts and when you think
about it
diagrammed you can explain it as the
construction
of the world around a particular
individual
it would include their local knowledge
about their plants and animals
within which they live then outside of
that
their land and management systems
then beneath that the social
institutions which they inhabit and
which they have influence upon
and then underneath all those nested
concepts comes the world
view and there are many different
worldviews or belief systems
about how humans think they exist within
relationship to nature
and the way most of the world or western
world lives is just one way
of thinking about that radical
indigenism
isn't a concept i made up it is actually
a concept that was developed by a
princeton professor and a citizen of the
cherokee nation eva
marie garud and she argues
for a rebuilding of current knowledge
through explorations of indigenous
philosophies and indigenous knowledge
that could be capable of generating new
knowledge and
completely new dialogues for us
so in low tech i really brought this
type of thinking into the sphere of
design
and sustainability which is incredibly
relevant in the context
of climate change and i've been arguing
for a new look at these types of
indigenous philosophies
of knowledge of information within
mythologies to try and think about how
can we improve our understanding of
technologies that are relative to
sustainability
and to resilience thinking and so low
tech
i see as a movement and it's a movement
to rebuild
this understanding of indigenous
philosophy and of
vernacular design to generate
new sustainable climate resilient
technologies
so scientists have acknowledged that we
are in the midst of the
sixth mass extinction but what we
haven't really
understood is that species extinction
alone is not going to be
the 21st century's greatest loss because
those same forces that drive species
extinction they also
endanger the indigenous nature-based
technologies
that we're not even really recognizing
at technologies
at this point in time that may actually
hold a key
to our survival and these are
technologies that have been
passed down and evolved through
generations in response to flood
and fire and drought and sea level rise
and even severe
weather events and these are the same
crises that we're facing today
and what seems so strange to me is that
when we talk about climate mitigation we
still think of it on the grounds of
conservation
pristine and undeveloped wetland forest
desert and mountain landscapes rather
than considering that there are
thousands of ways
that local communities design space
and live with nature and have adapted
and developed
their landscapes with incredibly
resilient
and sophisticated technologies that are
more advanced than the design thinking
that we
have and use today and so now i'm going
to take you
through a few of these technologies and
explain how they might be radically
re-envisioned
and change our understanding of what
sustainability and resilience could be
so living amongst the highest mountains
in the philippines
and calling themselves the sky people
the ifugao
are masters of terracing and they use
water
and soil and rocks as construction
techniques and tools and the terraces
that they form are unique micro
watersheds that
serve as rainwater filtration systems
for the waters that are passing through
this mountain landscape
and they're a combination of shallow
water very high
nutrient levels high primary
productivity and they
are incredibly ideal conditions for
growing organisms that form the base
of our food webs what that means is that
many species actually rely
on these rice terraces in these
incredible mountainous landscapes for
food
for water and for shelter and especially
birds that are actually flying through
and passing on their migrations through
this landscape and that makes them
really incredibly important for global
biodiversity so these constructed rice
terraces are actually one of our
most important ecosystem and they act as
these
massive absorption and water
purification
systems as well as nutrient and
biodiversity storehouses with
a scale and a steepness that's really
synonymous with
our skyscrapers in our cities their
biological
performance has the potential to really
inform how do we
integrate landscapes into our vertical
cities the vertical landscapes of our
cities and it really hints at how
our urban vertical environments could
become
also havens for aquatic terrestrial
and airborne biodiversity as well as
urban agriculture with incredible
irrigation systems
so in parts of the world where rivers
are usually contaminated with sewage
we can find there's one city of 15
million people that uses
its flood plains to treat the water that
is waste water and sewage water that is
coming
out of the city it does this through a
combination of sunshine
sewage and a symbiosis between algae
and bacteria the wastewater which comes
in about 95 percent
water and 5 waste
in this condition is then broken down
and then after that process of breaking
down the water moves into a series of
fish ponds that then clean the water in
a process
that takes about 30 days and on the
edges of the city
which is actually the city of calcutta
you can find this incredible wetland
system and this incredible wastewater
aquaculture system
and it's ribbon by highways and it's
uh flanked by this smoking escarpment of
all the city's trash called the darpa
you can find
this incredible indigenous technology
and it's composed of these 300
fish ponds that clean the city city's
water
while also producing the city's food
this innovation it's not just
a model for chemical and coal power free
water purification it also provides a
hundred
thousand jobs to the residents of the
city of calcutta
given that calcutta actually has no
other
formal treatment system at its core it's
actually the only way
that the wastewater coming out of the
core of the city of kolkata
can be cleaned before it enters the bay
of bengal
there's an islanding and housing system
also that's made from a single
species of reed and it's called the
altala islands
and the mudif houses and you can find
them in the southern wetlands of iraq
and this incredible waterborne community
and technology is constructed by the
madan people
and they construct these floating
islands by fencing off a section
of living reeds that are called the
casab
and then upon that living fence they
stack the dried reeds plus mud plus
dried breeze and mud until they create
this floating
platform and these mudhiff houses and
these altala floating platforms they've
actually
seen these depicted in sumerian urak
imagery so that would estimate this type
of construction technology
at about six and a half thousand years
old
and the casa breed is actually integral
not just to the construction of these
islands and these beautiful
cathedral-like houses but it's also
integral to every single aspect of life
for the madan people but also it is food
for water buffalo
it is flour for humans as well as
creating this material for these
incredible technologies of the floating
islands
and of the arched houses that are
actually constructed
in as little as three days and this
casabrai it is
so incredibly versatile that it can be
stacked into creating these islands it
can be
bundled to create these beautiful
columns it can be
woven to create floors and walls and
then it can even
be twisted so that it creates rope that
then
binds the buildings that they're
constructing
which are actually made without nails or
wood
or glass and these madan villages they
have been constructed
in the marsh and they stay afloat for
a generation so about 25 years
this last system that i included it
actually exhibits
this phenomenon of simultaneous
innovation
and the co-discovery of evolution by
darwin
and alfred russell wallace is perhaps
the most
famous yet relatively unknown case of
simultaneous innovation
in scientific history but then there are
all these other
unknown cases of simultaneous innovation
that have emerged
in isolated indigenous communities
who've been confronting
the same types of challenges in the same
types of
environments so for example islanding
technologies in iraq
can also be found in as islanding
technologies that are not exactly the
same
but similar in peru so what we find
is on the other side of the earth
situated on the highest
navigable lake in the world which sits
at
3 850 meters above sea level
we find 50 floating islands that are
built by the euros
community and they also make their
islands
from a single species of reed which is
called the tutorial reed and the
tutorial grows in the landscape
around which they construct these
islands initially these islands are
constructed by
cutting huge six foot by
six foot blocks into the peat which is
the mud that the base and the root
system
of these tutorials are actually
grown in and then they lash these bricks
together they
anchor them to the base of the lake
through wood and rope then
on top of that they overlay dried totoro
reed
until these islands are so squishy when
you walk on them that it feels like
you're actually walking across
a waterbed these islands also
stay afloat for about 25 years so
through the research i've actually
evolved
at this point in time 64 different
communities which use islanding
technologies and
they were once found in europe they're
currently found in asia
and africa and south america and
we haven't even started really exploring
these types of technologies
by designers who are developing some of
these floating cities and flooding
communities that we
quite possibly could be living on in the
future so in 1966
the architect cedric price asked a very
important question he asked if
technology is the answer
then what was the question and this
provoked this incredible
questioning and really critical
conversations that were happening in the
field of architecture
and people were thinking about what was
the impact of technology on
architecture and on cultures and even
on society at large i think it's really
important that we still keep on asking
this question today but 60 years later
i feel like i'm still asking a very
similar but
somewhat different question and that is
if
sustainability is the answer then what
was the question
because we keep going higher and we keep
going out wider
and we keep on going deeper to extract
but to what end will
sustainability really save us if we
don't systematically change
the way we're interacting with our earth
and keep on creating these types of
conditions
and we seem really fascinated
with the future and with with ideas of
sustainability and we often forget
as we look into the future that we also
have a past
that we can look to it's really hard to
solve
problems that were created with the same
set of solutions that created the
problem
in the first place so really the most
effective way
to mitigate climate change is to
recognize that there are solutions that
are embedded in
traditional ecological knowledge i
wonder what we could imagine if we were
to look at all the other different
cultures who have been developing
and scaling sustainable technologies
and those systems for millennia take for
example the kahumba
forest farming system of the chaga
people who live along the southern
slopes of mount kilimanjaro
so in this tropical montane forest
ecosystem
the chaga have actually added 650 new
species of food and medicinal plants
into the existing
multi-level canopies creating a forest
farming system
that is the size of los angeles another
example might be
these 1500 year old living root bridges
that are actually grown from two species
of ficus elastic a tree
across the rivers in an area of india
called mega layer and they're grown by a
tribe called the khasi people
the community have actually grown 75 of
these
structures and it's a means by which
they can cross the swollen rivers
in the monsoon season and they take
about 50 years to grow
but in this landscape they actually last
for centuries
and this is a landscape where any other
type of bridge will literally
rot in about 10 years so low tech
suggests
that nature based solutions to climate
change
they don't need to be passive
conservation
areas like forests and wetlands they can
be active they can be productive
they can be adaptive and they can be
complex coexistences
of many different types of species
both human and non-human and they can
use
biodiversity as a building block for the
future
so climate change has shown us that our
survival
it's not really dependent upon this idea
of superiority our survival is dependent
on this understanding of symbiosis and
using symbiosis in the way we design the
technologies of the future
and also shifting our thinking from this
idea of survival of the fittest
to survival of the most symbiotic is
going to be a really
critical first step thank you
thank you so much julia um that was
really fantastic and that
the visuals are really stunning and i i
think maybe one of the things that
didn't come across
in this uh was also the diagrams that
are in your book that that really
actually kind of exploded views of these
ancient technologies drawn with you know
modern architecture
kind of cad tools um i think is a really
beautiful addition too so i encourage
people to look at those
um and thank you for joining us for
questions we have um we have questions
coming in online that uh that kevin
kelly is sorting
and um and then stewart's gonna join us
for a question or two
um but i i really you know we're
standing in the middle of
this huge historic fire season in the
west
and it's interesting starting to hear
people um talk about the indigenous ways
of of managing the landscape that were
obviously different than the western
ways
uh you know for over the for the last
century i'm wondering if you've
done research into that yeah thank you
so much
um uh for having me here tonight and
um i have and i mean being from
australia
we have seen in the fires last year we
have a similar
situation that has been happening year
over year over year
last year was the worst fire fires that
we'd ever seen
we saw that landscapes that had been
traditionally burned or culturally
burned
they had seen like half a reduction of
the impact of those fires and had been
seen in other landscapes and these
types of management techniques they're
similar to the sort of western
preventative measures that are being
used
by um different um uh
you know people who are dealing with the
wildfires but
they're actually very different as well
because they've been learned over
generations they're very specific to
the types of ecosystems that the fires
are being burnt within
rather than being sort of universal
types
of applications that are
not so specific to place and specific to
the types of environments and soils and
blooming times of flowers and
trees and and the sort of reproductive
times of animals so
indigenous fire practices and management
techniques they
really understand the local ecosystem
and the intelligence of the local system
and they work with those local
ecosystems and those local dynamics and
that's the really
big difference apart from the fact that
in many places we actually don't use
those preventative fire
techniques at this point in time and
then we just see this all this
combustible fuel sitting there on the
ground
and that's why we have these sort of
raging tornado wildfires that just the
fronts and
the temperatures are so high the fronts
are so big that they're just completely
uncontrollable
yeah yeah i learned a new term this year
pyrocumulus
a word i didn't never wanted to know but
uh
yeah you remind me of the there's a
there's actually an indigenous clock
technology that i remember reading about
that the
um in um in the highlands
of um no i'm spacing it but they the
tribes there use
um the bird song throughout the day
different birds
chirp at different times of the day um
and so they
recognize the species of the of the
birds and they can tell you what time of
day it is even in
a in a canopied forest so yeah that's
very cool
um how many of these sites did you get a
chance to get to personally and versus
research
remotely i think well initially we did
35 case studies so there's actually
a whole lot more research that wasn't uh
in the book i would say of the 35 we
went i went to about half of those
sometimes it was through teaching
sometimes it was through jobs and
sometimes it was just through
travel and sometimes
some of these places were just not open
to the southern wetlands of iraq i was
invited but
having you had to get uh permission from
the government we got the permission and
then
their war broke out since uh war broke
out at that time and so
there wasn't a i wasn't able to travel
to those um areas but
interestingly those um those wetlands in
iraq they really just haven't been
photographed at all because of these
types of conditions so
somewhat some of the footage is really
kind of a time lapse of
what we know before but then there's
also a person i work with very closely
who lives there and who's
madan so he sort of sends some images as
well so we see
footage from 15 17 years ago and then we
see imagery coming out now
and so um i try to go to
all of the sites if i can um now that
we're writing more and more
some of that and at this point in time
it's a little bit more difficult
but um i think being on the ground and
really experiencing your
these scenarios and these places
myself is has always been the ambition
and really um
incredible for the research as well cool
um and uh kevin kelly had a question um
as he travels in or used to travel in
asia quite a bit
and seeing a lot of the younger
generation um
abandoning the countryside did you was
this coming up at all especially with
these things that you know high
maintenance
areas like the terraces or those you
know tree bridges and things like that
yeah and i mean i i worked in bali
for a period of time working with them
in their first unesco
world heritage site and par you know
part of the dilemma is these are
incredible systems these are incredible
technologies and cultures
but in this um transition
of this certain paradigm of development
and progress there's this progression
towards wanting to
um modernize in a certain way that is
being sort of
imported from america or australia or
other places around the world and then
there's sort of
there's this transition of jobs that
people are
really and younger people are um
investing their time in
and i think that you know this work
really is sort of like
saying can we can we redefine
like what this idea of progress is can
we sort of
begin to understand that perhaps this um
modern
you know high-tech flashy um story
that that we sell of the west being the
best maybe that isn't really and
what we're coming to understand is that
that that one
universal paradigm of what progress and
technology and and
being modern is doesn't work
um it's failing us and so we need other
other types of ideas and other paradigms
and these these are them
and so abandoning these types of um
you know these types of systems for the
sale of this other type of
idea or ideology um you you do see it in
in a lot of these places but then
there's a resurgence and it and
it's starting to grow that with climate
change
and and with um you know
um this sort of this sort of
redirection of how globalization is
being seen i think people are really
starting to
take root in local ideas and
understandings and really become much
prouder of individual cultures and i
think that that we're starting to see a
shift
and we're seeing it as shift sort of
globally in sort of
people transitioning into ideas of
retaining
their identity and retaining culture and
and sort of
and we we've seen you know that this is
something that people are becoming
um much prouder of and so i hope
in a way that this book begins to say
like these technologies are incredibly
important these are technologies that we
need to preserve and and
and to and to use and and to be proud of
yeah excellent and i think that's what
really struck me about the book is it
took a thing where
it kind of flips the coin on on old tech
and new tech for sure and the i
i really loved your kind of your layers
of indigenous technology thing and
it reminded me so much of the pace layer
diagram that we use it long now of
layers of
of time which actually stuart adapted
from when he wrote how buildings learn
so it's adapted from
basically architecture and we adapted it
to time and and
you've kind of built a similar one in
in world views and things like that so
it's very cool
and uh nick uh from online asks
he asked if there's other places that
either are using the root bridges or
should be using the root bridges is that
detect a portable technology do you
think
um i know that people around the world
have written to me and said that they're
trying to
grow root bridges oh really different
places there's a
there's a um farm in africa and south
africa where they're trying they're
experimenting with growing
these a sort of version of living root
bridges
um and someone from australia has
written me and said that they're doing
that as well but
not i haven't found independent
communities but interestingly enough
they think that that living root bridge
was actually imported from lao
when a community of uh people from lao
actually migrated about a thousand years
ago up to that area of cherapunji
and so it actually is a system that
migrated from lao
up into northern india well that's very
cool
the yeah and the simultaneous innovation
part the story is
is i think really interesting and i
pointed out it happens in science it
happened in math
um but and of course i think certain
landscapes
um and climates are going to i think
cause some of these things to happen
and i suspect fire management technology
was
is also a space where there's
simultaneous in all kinds of
hot dry landscapes around the world that
that that's happened as well
um let's see um bobi rachova
from our feed asks what do you envision
in the intersection of tek and ai for
the next 10 000 years
easy question i've thought about this so
this is actually not super hard
um i think you know
ai and and tk i think there's a really
interesting
um understanding there's there's a lot
of ways that ai
doesn't take into consideration other
frameworks or other understandings and
one of those is traditional economic
ecological knowledge and
the same as that western science doesn't
um uh
isn't inclusive a lot of uh traditional
ecological knowledge so
if western science and western data is
what is embedding itself within
our ai what are we not what are we not
recognizing and so therefore if we're
doing you know we're using ai
to try and understand environmental
systems like forestry
what are some of the symbiotic
relationships with their embedded into
forestry like relationships of the
mycorrhizal layer and how
the transportation of you know different
nutrients or
we know that in western science but what
are some of the sort of stories within
and understandings within indigenous
knowledge that we haven't recognized yet
that could really inform us in
understanding say okay
boundaries are inconsequential we need
to think of holistic
understandings of el nino and its effect
upon
masting of huge forest systems or
reproduction of huge
forest systems which we understand
sometimes from the mythologies
of indigenous peoples and their
understandings about
um very specific climates and and places
so
going back to you know the question
about pyrotechnology
and the relationship between
preventative burning of the west and
preventative cultural burning of
aboriginal people
there is just much deeper understandings
in
those relationships to place and culture
and it's embedded in culture for
generations and generations so how can
we see those types of understandings
into ai and that's where i think it gets
really interesting
and how can we think about ai
systemically embedded with environmental
deep environmental thinking how would
that change the outcome of the future
that we could envision
no it reminds me very much of our our
talk uh with our last speaker also from
australia who
um who's talking about ai and kind of
and
basically just human human ethics and
how that fits in i think those
all tie in together um and it actually
it's a good
tie into the next question um from jerry
machelsky um
really asking like how do we and sounds
like you've already been doing this
and so i'd like to get your insight in
it is how do we connect
scientific process and thinking
with indigenous ways of of doing things
and
how are you how are you finding those
two worlds connecting
um i mean i think the the most obvious
answer to that would be
to um to bring indigenous people
to to the to into the conversations and
to bring their knowledge bases
into um the sort of and combine them
with the knowledge basis of
western scientific thinking and and
recognize that this is a form of
scientific thinking and it's
and it's a highly sophisticated form of
scientific thinking
and apart from like what i do i think
the biggest problem is that um you know
when i'm working on design projects and
have
worked with indigenous communities a lot
of governments won't recognize the
communities as being incredibly
important and vital
bearers of knowledge and stewardship and
understandings of those landscapes
and and you know that's that's one of
the biggest hurdles
is really um you know convincing and
bringing the right people to the table
and right people to meet and collaborate
and and to share knowledge
and and to allow us to move forward
there's a sustain
saying that i heard the other days you
know this social look you know the
global
um social climate justice movement you
need to get beside or behind indigenous
people and allow them to lead us and i
think that's going to be incredibly
important for us
cool i love that um let's bring in
stuart i know that
he's working on a book on maintenance
and this this crosses over pretty
perfectly
well there's a thing on maintenance that
bears relation here which is
um maintenance usually is pretty boring
uh creation is exciting and a lot of the
kind of projects that you're describing
are highly collaborative a lot of people
got to get together at the same time and
make the thing happen
and one of the ways i suspect that
people work around the boring
aspect of maintenance is to
turn it into ceremony or ritual or you
know make a big kind of
dancy musical religious or whatever
deal about it did you find that
out there yes i did that's you know a
wonderful parallel
there was a system called the subac and
it's in bali and that's the rice terrace
system
and they have a system of
ceremonies rituals all throughout the
year and the one i always refer to which
i think is just
so beautiful is the singing to the baby
rice
when they're sort of maintaining and
they're planting
and first putting the plugs of of the
rice which they grow somewhere else
initially
into the terraces they sing to them and
i talk about
ceremony as being a way to remember to
remember
how to do something so embedded within
the sort of the singing and
is the knowledge is the care is the
ideas of the maintenance
and then next year when at the same time
you remember
that you need to remember all these
different things because the song will
tell you how to do that
and apart from that sounds like stephen
lansing's work in golly
it is steven uh and he he actually talks
in the series way back when we started
it was wonderful
uh did you find other cases where ritual
and ceremony are put to use
um it's it's it's really is sort of
all the way throughout there there's
always a sort of
recognition of the seasonality and
understanding of seasonality
and those critical points of sort of
different types of extremes
that um you know okay there's going to
be an annual fire so let's prepare
let's um figure out and understand like
how do we prepare
because we've done this many times so
we'll know how to do it this year and i
think sort of you know
that's part of the stuff that we've lost
so one of the communities that i look at
they're called
the anawane people there in brazil they
literally
live in ceremony for nine months of the
year it's called the aqua festival
and it's all about the sort of the
fishing the smoking of the fish they
build these beautiful temporary dams
that were
that was an imagery that was in the
lecture and and everything is sort of
about
sort of sowing the the um
uh they use sort of like a tuber and and
collecting the fish
and their relationship with fish which
is really sort of
celestial and astrological and and bears
these all these spiritual relationships
but it's i mean so interesting could you
conceive of us living for nine months of
the year in ceremony
sort of to have that relationship and
celebrate that relationship with nature
and life so yeah all through all
throughout there's all mythologies and
and
understandings and ceremonies that
really are about how to recreate and
maintain these environments
now trust me another angle here is is
language
uh ecological understanding
is often embedded in local language
and when the language is lost much that
knowledge is lost
uh did you find any of that in your work
yeah there there was actually a
community
um called the cayapo and they used fire
power technology again to um very
very cool fires to selectively burn
patches and then they
um then they sort of uh implant
agriculture into those landscapes
underneath the canopy of the tree which
they save
and they have like nine different words
for the word ash
because ash is so important to the
fertilization of the soil
that there's all these different types
of ways which you can describe
ash which i just think though having an
expansive
um descriptive language for something
that we have one single word to describe
really really shows you like what is
what's the priorities
for this particular type of community
and and by
by the words by the number of words
which they use to describe sort of
something that we use one word for yeah
are the languages being actively
preserved by the
people i mean that must vary enormously
from being totally lost and they have to
reinvent their world
and others where like most of the north
american tribes now are
really actively reviving their languages
uh are you finding that elsewhere in the
world
um i mean language
specifically i mean i don't focus on it
very
very specifically but from my
understanding as well
um there is a there is a revival of
language in some locations and sort of
there isn't in a lot of other locations
and i think
you know i'm speaking about say you know
countries that are starting to sort of
unify
their languages but often you'll see
that these indigenous tribes
they don't actually exist so much within
the sort of dominant
governmental understanding and framework
as that country so you would say in
india the
the people who are the khasi there is a
really strong revival and learning and
passing down of language
because often they'll somewhat operate
outside of sort of
this the the most dominant governmental
structure
so they're they're within that but they
sort of also recognize themselves
outside of that and i think that's
that's incredibly important and vital
and sort of
probably should be more recognized and
by by countries
to empower these communities to to keep
that knowledge
to recognize that our future is going to
be dependent on these understandings
you're here thank you thank you stuart
we're going to actually get we're able
to get kevin kelly live so we'll
bring him in next kevin hello there you
are
hi welcome hi and um
sort of following up a little bit on an
earlier question
about keeping the kids on the farm
because in order to maintain these
traditions and this knowledge you really
do have to have the next generation stay
and in my experience they're running as
fast as they can with one-way tickets
into the cities because they have wi-fi
and um
did you have any thoughts about how you
can reverse that flow
so that a young person growing up with a
tribal language
isn't going to leave and
would want to stay and find
a way to have the wi-fi and their
ceremonies because if it doesn't
happen then then those villages will
empty out
yeah i mean the work that i've done has
often been
uh sort of large-scale master-planning
work within unesco world heritage sites
so that looking at that particular
problem even in these landscapes that
are kind of celebrated as
the you know of outstanding universal
value and you might
think that there it would be easier for
to sort of
attract and have youth stay what we've
been looking at is really trying to
understand how you can embed it's
usually economics
what i've found is that there's it's
more attractive to go and work in
tourism industry or other types of
industries because
of money so if if we can think about how
to
layer in different types of revenue
streams that are
that are not just from tourism that
might be about introducing
symbiotic um economic
um products to those local landscapes so
could you embed
um new types of technologies of
coming from coir or or coconut palm
matting
into a stream of rice farming so that
they're
in an off season because also these
systems work seasonally
and so there's off seasons and there's
seasons when there's a lot of work and
so
is there a way that you can sort of
build out the economic
framework so it's not just dependent
upon one single
um um uh
job but it's also it has like rel
jobs that are relative and and sort of
um amplify that that landscape at the
same time as well so
i mean there is going to be definitively
we know that that
75 of the population we think it's
predicted will be living in cities and
by 2050 um i do know in countries like
china that there
there is this new um
pride and a new recognition that these
indigenous landscapes are incredibly
important
and that there's there is a resurgence
happening that's regional
to and sort of specific and maybe
national that
people are recognizing that this erasure
is happening really quickly
and that and there's a lot to lose and
therefore you know
there there's a movement of youth saying
that we actually do need to retain these
landscapes and we do need to stay in
these places
um i can actually imagine governments
funding people to keep the terraces
up and running because maybe even making
robots to um tend them because they're
so narrow you can't get a tractor in
um yeah so that might be something that
is actually funded from outside in other
words it's not really economically
feasible just to grow rice but it's
economically feasible to have them there
because they're just
beautiful and they maintain all the
other
all the other things that you mentioned
that the right tourists do or for
tourism as well
or the ecosystem services so you know in
the future when we're saying okay well
we don't have a lot we have too much
carbon dioxide um we don't have a lot of
clean air
like how do we or or these kolkata
wetlands that basically clean the water
the sewerage water the sea of calcutta
for free
what's the reparation for these
communities they're basically providing
free services
if we start to think of these
technologies as infrastructures that
provide all these services
to cities in the that they sit in the
landscapes of these cities
where do we sort of see where do we sort
of build in these
um these sort of unrecognized or
indirect costs because we're starting to
see these indirect
costs of our impact upon the climate now
when we all wear masks and
if we're in oregon we're wearing masks
because the air we can't breathe the air
and because of covered so
we're going to have to start building in
you know these indirect costs
and these indirect environmental costs
in the way that we understand and
and you know manage our landscapes so
maybe that's another way
that we could start to think about that
that equation and i know that your
research is really focusing on
indigenous
knowledge indigenous perspectives
as it pertains to traditional knowledge
but indigenous can also
be the source of new technologies and
new things
and i was wondering if you were paying
much attention to
not just traditional things being
maintained
but actually some of these communities
as sources of
actually completely original new ideas
that could only have occurred
in a isolated place
because they were thinking differently i
mean i think that's
kind of the it's kind of the thesis of
the radical indigenism is that
part of it is to like look at look at
the old knowledge
and recognize it recognize it as new and
and to recognize that new conversations
can come from it
um part of the next amount of research
that we're starting to do
which is kind of like a sneak peek into
the future and where we're headed
is to do exactly that is to say okay
where
are their their new forms and
and new new recognitions of technologies
that are being evolved today maybe not
in those particular
landscapes in the same way but maybe
they are happening in
and we i haven't come across that we've
come across it in some
locations that we're like our scientists
our communities our designers like
which indigenous people are actually
sort of making those leaps which
communities are selling to
to evolve those systems and how and i
have spoken to a number of communities
in africa where they're recognizing
traditional
technologies and the innovation is there
coupling them with
contemporary business solutions to to
figure out how to scale
those technologies and you know that's
related to economics um and and
and different just assistance with
trying to create business models that
are conducive to those types of
technologies
and those communities so that's the
other sort of
new sort of understanding and and
and innovation yeah cool that's great
thank you kevin
yep and um jenna
uh asks that uh i said i should love to
hear more
uh about advice for other landscape
architects
who want to be able to bring this kind
of thinking into
um into their field just just as you
have been doing this research as
a landscape architect yeah um
you know i think that as designers
sometimes we're
broadened to work with different
communities if we're doing any work that
is around the world in in other
countries
and we come with a perspective and we're
giving our
expertise and we're giving out expertise
based upon
a selection of understandings and a
selection of technologies
that we bring to the table but what i
don't think we're very good at at this
point in time
is going into situation scenarios and
doing the research on the ground and and
really understanding local conditions
and talking to indigenous communities
talking to local communities
and say and and really having that
speculative
and analytical lens on to say well what
is it here
how can i catalyze that because if we
were to amplify what already exists
rather than to
you know reinvent the wheel that's going
to be a faster way to mitigate
climate change and to really really you
know
shift our thinking and shift our impact
than if we sort of you know erase and
and and we come in as these sort of
experts
all knowing and and sort of overlay with
ideas that perhaps aren't really going
to work for particular communities
aren't
responsive and respectful to different
ecosystems and
and don't have an understanding of like
climatic extremes that exist within that
that area so and the other thing i think
is to really
um you know from the very outset to
bring in
other stakeholders who probably and
other people
who are not normally brought to the
conversation and that's something that
we need to be
far more aware of and and use our
position
and our interdisciplinary way of
thinking
to to bring other people to those
conversations that aren't being being
brought to the conversations because
we need to show clients and governments
and and and different people that we
interact with and we're responsive to
that there is far more knowledge and
technology
and innovation and understanding out
there that is recognized right now and
so
i think our place is to really champion
these ideas and to bring them and to
spread them and and
and to um to like build them into the
way that we work as professionals
yeah starting by doing a lot more
listening than killing
peter laden um asks um
says you didn't mention biotech and i
assume he means the kind of
our high-tech version of biotech not the
the low-tech version
how do you think that that category of
technology crosses over here i mean i
suspect there is
there is biotechnology happening
especially in some of these sewage
treatment
systems and things like that i i think
what
what i think is really interesting about
some of these systems is i call it sort
um next generation of green technology
or you know we we now we're you know
we're moving into a phase of um green
tech where
it's wind and water and tidal and and
and son and what might be the next
generation is really looking at symbolic
relationships and
and how symbiotic relationships and
even down to the material and molecular
scale
like in the east calcutta wetlands where
it's sunshine
and sewerage and algae and bacteria
that's your energy system so that's your
producer
in that ecological scenario it also
becomes your consumer
and your reducer which you know all
these systems are embedded in one so
when we design
something that sort of reduces our waste
like a wastewater facility we design it
to do one thing
we don't design it to produce our food
to provide thousands hundreds of
thousands of jobs to
you know mitigate um carbon
to clean water we don't we just we don't
design it with these
multiple multiplicity of functions and i
think
that's where it gets really interesting
and it can happen at that molecular
scale
all the way up to the macro scale where
you can design this system to
protect a town from flooding as well as
to
clean its water to clean the sewage out
of its water and that's where it gets so
interesting
is like also the sort of how do these
systems work within themselves
but then how do they keep on working
beyond the way that we design them just
because
if you in nature if you put in a in a
change at a really high level it has
this thing called a trophic cascade
where
all these different different scenarios
can play out that
keep on building biodiversity beyond
what we can even model at this point
time that's what i think is so
interesting about the systems if we can
scale them
the the opportunity for changing
biodiversity
and and impacting climate really could
be exponential we don't know
right and uh you mentioned earlier that
you're doing new research for a new
project
can you talk a little bit more about
about that and so is it going to be
another book or
yes um yeah i'm doing research for
another a book there is it was always
planned as a series of books
um and uh
it's sort of this next book is really
looking at a specific
um a specific type of landscape so we're
diving much deeper
into one particular type of landscape
um and then sort of trying to really
think about also what is what is that
relationship if we were
to think of like what's high tech um
and and saying to actually the the
ambition is to start to co-author with
indigenous scientists and decisions
designers and
and architects so that there's so many
more voices
that are being built and embedded
into into the landscape of the book and
into sort of the territory of low tech
that there's going to be
um you know the possibility for
this to have a really large scale impact
on the way that we think
um we'll be there and um and this is
inspired by a question from iron
lowenstein
from from one of the feeds and we're
coming up on the end here
as we hit the top of the hour but
you mentioned world views and how
different those are
among among different groups and
obviously they're radically different
between the western
society and these indigenous tribes and
i'm wondering how do you think these
things are going to
to mesh both in the technol technology
as well as the cultural space
i mean i think my ambition is that maybe
if we start to recognize these
different mythologies of technology that
i call them in the book and
these different sort of world belief
systems and ways of
really understanding how humans can
relate to nature that will
you know we have a sort of a dominant
global understanding of how humans
relate to nature and it's not
incredibly healthy and it's not
incredibly
based upon nature but i think what i
think is going to happen is that
we'll begin to recognize that we need to
form a more nature-based
culture globally that that whatever that
universal
sort of global culture that we speak
about and recognize
now is going to become more nature based
in
universally nature based and it will be
informed by all these different
understandings and recognitions of all
the different ways that
we can live with nature so that we're
now recognizing okay agriculture
doesn't have to be monoculture enough
doesn't have to destroy the soil and
and um you know uh you know
take all the water and and then pollute
it so we
we're recognizing now that regenerative
agriculture is incredibly important so
that's a movement towards more
nature-based culture within
fashion and i think that we're going to
start seeing those incidents happening
more and more again
even to the point where my ambition is
like how can we see that
starting to happen in industry how can
we see that happening selling to plan
instead of
the way we design cities so i think
that's sort of the next way
and we're on we're already on those
tracks we're
i know that sometimes we all feel like
we're very distant from that future that
we envision that we want to live in but
i also
think that we need to recognize that
we're moving through that phase of
getting to those spaces and we're
probably constantly going to be in that
mode of transition
it's never going to be an end point when
we're there we're constantly in that
phase and we're always just being
reminded that we need to
speed it up at this point in time and we
need to expand it and we need to
you know recognize it faster and
acknowledge the science
but we're getting there and so you know
i think you know
thankful to these types of lecturers and
people spreading the word in these
formats that
we are we are getting there and and you
know it's not
you know sometimes it feels quite dismal
but it's actually a place of like
optimism to think about our future and
to think about what it could be
well what a nice way to end thank you so
much julia this was really great and
uh your your book is on my coffee table
for uh the foreseeable futures
ev everyone comments on it that sees it
they love it thank
thanks xander take care thank you all